Hello, so we'll be doing something a little
different because I am going to take you on
a trip to the zoo. It's a zoo with Monkeys,
with rhinos and an aquarium, more specifically
there will be Spider Monkey, Rhino, and SquirrelFish,
I'll be talking about JavaScript engines.
JavaScript has got incredibly fast we look
at how JavaScript engines work and optimisation
techniques, I'll show you a few examples of
how you can write code that takes advantage
of those optimisations rather than working
again them, I won't focus on the differences
between the engines, instead we will look
at what they have in common, the optimisation
examples work independently of the browser
choice.
So, a little bit of history, SpiderMonkey
is the JavaScript engine that was first, the
very first JavaScript engine, written in 1995
back then used in Netscape communicator and
after several rewrites that's the engine we
have in Firefox today.
Of course SpiderMonkey comes with Monkey friends,
trace money JagerMonkey, TraceMonkey and IonMonkey,
they help SpiderMonkey took be even faster.
Then in 2002 the squirrel fish was written,
for safari and webkit, we also have rhinos,
it's a word play, it's a Java script written
in oracle, so the next animal, I'm sorry,
engine, it's V 8, it's the JavaScript engine
in Chrome and it came out in 2009, Microsoft
jscript or Chakra was also one of the older
ones that came in 1986, that's what we have
in Internet Explorer and Edge. With V 8 and
jscript I ran out of animals, that's the end
of our trip to the zoo, sadly for the rest
of the talk there won't be any more animals,
let's look at the technical side.
As I already mentioned the engines have all
been rewritten several times and that was
mainly ton for performance, we want fast JavaScript,
we want the websites to be fast and responsive,
we need good performance. How fast are we?
here are some benchmarks over the last ten
years, the SunSpider benchmark, as you can
see the score gets higher, fee got faster
and faster. Ok, are we fast yet, we got faster,
there is a website, 'Are we faster.com', you
see similar pictures, another benchmark, different
versions of Chrome and Firefox, as you can
see they got faster, massive performance improvements.
All right. So, yes we are faster, but we are
faster compared to an older version of ourselves,
does it actually mean we are fast? We are
faster than 20 years ago, ok, but are we fast?
Let's compare to something where we know that
it really is fast.
Let's have a race between C++ and JavaScript,
we know C++ is fast. So, the contenders are
C++ and JavaScript and the race track are
prime numbers. A basic example I want to compute
the first 25,000 prime numbers and see how
fast the JavaScript compared to C++.
So, on the left you have C++ and on the right
you have JavaScript, don't worry, you don't
need to read thorough the algorithm I just
want to give you a quick idea, it's fairly
short, it easily fits on the page and the
C++ and JavaScript code, they do the same
things, same algorithm.
Ok, so when I run this, with C++, I first
printout the 25,000 prime number, which is
that one, to make sure my algorithm is correct,
it took me a little bit over 6 seconds, 6.2,
seconds, so how did JavaScript do? So I ran
this running D 8 the debugging shell for d8
makes it really easy to time it, I ran the
prime number example in JavaScript, I get
the correct answer so that's good. It's barely
slower than C++, 6.7 seconds. So if you do
the maths, JavaScript is less than 14% slower
than C++. I think this is really amazing,
those are amazing numbers, because what's
so special about this, why is it surprising
that JavaScript can calculate prime numbers
almost as fast as C++. Well C++
is statically typed, before you run your code
you have to specify for every variable what
type it is, so even at compile time the compiler
knows exactly what it will get, knows it will
get an integer, string or what class it gets.
Before run time you can optimise the machine
code that you get and then you get really
fast code once you actually execute it.
JavaScript is dynamically typed, you don't
have this information, only at run time do
we know what we get, we can't generate optimised
code ahead of time.
Just to make sure here, did compile C++ with
-03 optimisation flag, if you don't optimise
your code when compiling, JavaScript would
be way faster than C++ version of this, it's
ahead of time optimised code in C++ and it's
just a little bit faster than JavaScript.
Ok, so in the next 20 minutes we will look
at what JavaScript engines are doing to get
to this massive performance.
So a little bit of background, your classic
compiler has four components, lLexer, the
parser, it takes tokens and generates the
- the translator translates that tree into
byte code and then the account code is interpreted.
There is basically two main types of compilers,
ahead of time compilation and ‘just in time’
compilation. When it's ahead of time, before
you run it, you compile everything if possible,
you optimise the machine code that you get
and then you run it. Obviously C++ is ahead
of time. Why do I say obviously, you have
to do two separate steps, you call the compiler
that gives you an executable, then in the
second step you call the compiler, so clear
separation. So the benefit of a ahead of time
compilation you can take your time to optimise
this code, to get really could machine code
so when you run it it's very fast.
JavaScript on the other hand uses a 'Just
in time' compiler, so we're not compiling
everything up front ahead of time, for once
it would not be great if you opened a website
and you have to wait for all the JavaScript
code to compile before anything starts and
also since it's dynamically typed we could
not generate ahead of time good machine code.
So we do it, just in time. This is sometimes
also called 'Lazy compilation' we only compile
what we need as we want to execute it.
Ok this is good, we don't have a lot of information
ahead of time so we do just in time compilation,
but usually just in time compilation is very
slow, you don't have the big picture, you
can't optimise, so the machine code you get
does not run very fast.
So how do we get the almost C++ performance
if we are using just in time compilation?
Well, the basic concept that all modern JavaScript
engines use are hidden classes. So we don't
have hidden classes, at least until ECMA script,
but behind the scenes the JavaScript engines
assign a type or hidden class to any object.
So, integers and strings obviously have different
types of different classes, also objects have
hidden classes. Going
to use this example to show you how the engine
in the background assigns the hidden classes.
I've constructed a function for a point that
takes two arguments and assigns them to x
and y , when I instantiate a new point a,
my engine creates a point object, it's a pointer
and now when I look at the constructor, the
engine says, "Ok, so this point object has
a hidden class, let's call it z0", so my object
has class z0, I go through and assign x , the
engine is saying ok, we’ll take Z 0 and
add an x to it, as the first member, I'm getting
a new hidden class, C 1, it's the hidden class
that comes out of Z 0 if you had member x
to it, Z 1, opposite zero you have the value
for x .
Ok, if you go on in the constructor we do
the same things for y , we have C 1 and we
add y to it, from the 1 we get another hidden
class and C 2, where x and y in. Point object
now has hidden class C 2 which we get by adding
an x and then a y . If we instantiate another
point the compiler goes through the same steps
but can reuse C 1 and C 2, in the end both
A and B will have hidden class C 2, which
makes sense, they are very similar objects
generated the same way and we probably want
them treated the same way later at run time.
If we change the order of assigning x and
y for example, or if we assign another variable,
then the two objects would not have the same
hidden class, the order is important and then
also the same variables. If you are not sure
if two objects have the same hidden class
you can easily check. If you pass in the flag,
allow native syntax, then you can call a map
to check if two objects really have the same
hidden class. If that was confusing with the
order or if you are not sure that two things
there are same, this is how you can check.
I instantiate A and B, they have an x and
a y and have the same hidden class. Now if
I had another variable to A, they don't have
the same hidden class any more.
So, in practice that means we want the same
objects to have the same hidden class so it's
good practice to always instantiate all your
members in the constructor function. So rather
do this, we're in the constructor function
you said x and y , then this.
So, initial all objects and functions.
The compiler is always keeping track of stuff
and adding hidden classes how does that make
it faster. The hidden classes there are basis
for in line caching. So in line caching is
what gives us a big performance boost, what
it does is we're caching function, so if we
have a function do something of A, when we
want to execute it we compile it into a machine
code and into machine code for anything that
looks like an A, anything that has the hidden
class of A, now we cache the machine code,
the next time we come across, do something,
rather than compile it again for anyone that
looks like a B, we just check if A and B are
similar, if they have the same hidden class
we can use the code we already generated.
If A and B have the same hidden class we don't
have to do all the same work, only if A and
B are different in the sense they don't have
the same hidden class, we have to recompile
and
generate the machine instructions and then
probably cache that version for later use.
What does this mean in practice? I have a
silly function twice here, takes an argument
A and runs A+ A, if I call twice on the string
I expect the string with concat - a million
times in the loop, I'm called in randomly
on a integer or string.
Now for a million times it takes about six
seconds, I'm changing this a little bit, instead
of twice I'm making two functions, twice string
and twice int, they are exactly the same functions
they get an argument and return A+ A, the
intention with the name, I call twice string
only on strings and twice only on integers.
Then again in the loop a million times I randomly
call twice string on A or twice on 4. So the
output module, the randomness is exactly the
same of my programme before, just calling
A+ A, I call two separate functions.
Let's look at how long this takes, the first
example took five seconds, sorry, six seconds,
but this one with the two functions it only
takes five seconds. So we have about 20% speed
up, it's not great, but it's a speed up so
that's good.
In the first example where we only had one
function, that function is called a polymorphic
function, because the parameter it gets come
in different shapes, polymorphic, they come
as int or string. In the second example the
faster one both functions are considered monomorphic
because they always get the same input the
twice string always only got strings so the
takeaway, monomorphic functions are better
than polymorphic function don't switch up
the type of your parameters.
Here's a disclaimer though I am talking about
optimisation, premature optimisation is the
root of all evil. Don't go home and change
all your polymorphic functions. In the example
I just had I ran it a million times, I got
about a second faster, so probably your application
is not calling anything a million times, and
if you go and change your polymorphic function
you probably won't see any speed up overall.
The only thing you might happen you introduce
bugs by typos or other mistakes. It's always
when you talk about optimisation, don't blindly
optimise. Our JavaScript engine the compiler
is already a just-in-time compiler already,
that's not quite the speed we saw in the C++
example. So, the trick that all modern JavaScript
engines use is that they have at least 2 compilers,
they have us regular just-in-time compiler
and an optimised just-in-time compiler so
what happens just before we go through our
tokens, abstract syntax, bytecode then pass
it on to just-in-time compiler, which does
it’s work but now it's profiling and when
it realises that it's running a function a
lot of times it says ooh this is a hot function
because we're running it a lot, and the optimised
just-in-time compiler should take over. So
for any function that’s been run a lot the
optimising just-in-time compiler generates
faster machine code for that.
So anything that's run a lot can be executed
faster. But you see there’s a back arrow
going back from the optimised to regular just-in-time
compiler, well this happens if the optimised
compiler has read the machine code for a function,
all of a sudden we call this function with
a different hidden class then we can't use
the machine code and instead we fall back
to the old slower just-in-time compiler.
So in V8 the optimised compiler is called
Crankshaft added in 2010 in Microsoft Chakra.
They call it a full just-in-time compiler,
SquirrelFish has not one but 2 just-in-time
compilers: DFG and FTL. It's faster than light
and SpiderMonkey has IronMonkey which helps
for better performance. Another thing that
a lot of compilers, do they leave out that
step of translating into bytecode. That gives
you a little bit of performance.
Let's look at this twice example again this
time with the optimised compiler turned on
so minus minus crankshaft, that's the default
option. Earlier on I had it explicitly turned
off. Let's have the optimisation on, the same
examples as before, the polymorphic and monomorphic
functions, let's see how fast that is. We
went from 6 and 5 seconds down to 1 second,
that's already good that's a 5, 6 times speedup
but for the monomorphic function we see an
even better speedup, we're down to 90 milliseconds
now. So with modern engines if you by default
use the optimised just-in-time compiler this
really makes it faster.
We can nicely see what's going on here, when
we call the monomorphic example the faster
one with minus minus trace optimisation, then
you see we're optimising twice string because
twice string is always called with a string,
and the optimising compiler can now handle
this and the same for twice int. The other
example was the polymorphic function we don't
see optimisation. They are for random and
the polymorphic example crankshaft never really
kicks in so we don't have massive speedup.
There's another neat thing, if you ran twice
always on an integer we always call it on
4 and any after 10,000 loop iterations we
call it on a string. Then we see the following.
So, since we're always calling it on an integer
we can optimise it so optimising twice but
then we get to 10,000 once we're running it
just once with a string but that forces the
compiler to throw out this optimised version
of twice when it's called with an integer
because all of a sudden you cannot use that
machine code you generated.
So take away, monomorphic functions are better
than polymorphic functions. A few more things
to avoid are try/catch statements, anything
with eval, so V8 says I am not optimising
that at all. SquirrelMonkey can do it a little
bit but only the simple examples, avoid "with",
don't do switch statements with more than
128 cases they can't be optimised or maintained.
If you have 4 in loops keep your
keys local so don't forget var in front of
it. If you use any of that that will really
slow down your code because you can't use
the optimising compiler. So here's an example
of the Fibonacci series, Jennifer already
mentioned the series earlier, it's a sequence
of number that starts off with 11, you get
the next number always by adding the last
2 numbers. So the algorithm is for the Fibonacci
number of n, you just have to add the Fibonacci
number of n-1 plus the Fibonacci number of
n-2. We have this nice recursive algorithm,
and I stop the recursion when n is smaller
than 2
because the first 2 entries are 1 and 1. So
we wrote the algorithm but for some reason
we left an eval 2+2 in there but it's after
the statement, it really shouldn't change
anything, but now when I run this code n=35
I can see that the compiler says optimisation.
Reason function calls eval. Just because I
had the online in there that didn't change
anything about the algorithm, we can't optimise
it, it takes about 4 seconds.
Ok let's go ahead and fix that remove that
line, it's after the return so it really doesn't
change the code, let's run it again. So we
went from 4 seconds to 200 milliseconds, and
if you put the flag trace optimisation you
see the Fibonacci function a nice recursive
function always called on integers works perfectly
fine with the optimising compiler so from
4 seconds to 200 milliseconds that's a big
speedup, but remember this year, don't prematurely
optimise. Let's look at this example again.
So for every n we have to add the Fibonacci
number of n-1 and n-2. That means if we increase
n by 1 we're doubling the effort so we have
exponential complexity. No, that's not what
we want. This example is good because we can
really easily change the algorithm, so a simple
trick is just remember the Fibonacci numbers
you have already calculated by saving them
in array a, when you have calculated one use
that instead of recalculating it all the time.
So we have linear complexity instead of exponential
complexity, let's look at how fast this is.
So the exponential example when we delete
eval was down to 200 milliseconds or 180,
the linear example I didn't even bother to
take eval out, that only took 67 milliseconds.
So remember when you want to do optimisation,
don't blindly optimise for the compiler, make
sure you know your bottle neck and fix your
algorithms or whatever else is wrong.
As you saw on this example, JavaScript is
almost as fast as native C++ code which is
amazing considering that JavaScript is a dynamically
type language where you can do ahead-of-time
complication, and since the compilers rely
heavily on hidden classes, and inline caching
your application works best if it's statically
typed in nature. Try to avoid polymorphic
function, make several functions that are
monomorphic instead. Use structure initialisation
that you make sure all your objects do have
the same hidden class, if they are the same
kind of object, also avoid things like eval
so you don't stop the optimising compiler.
Thank you, if you have any questions please
come find me I look forward to talking to
you.